dos semanas de encierro culminaron con
la detención del obispo rolando álvarez
el viernes por la mañana fue sacado
contra su voluntad de su casa en
matagalpa y trasladado a la capital
managua a 130 kilómetros según las
autoridades se encuentra bajo arresto
domiciliario en la capital la policía
había rodeado su vivienda desde el 4 de
agosto cuando álvarez había grabado este
vídeo
he querido salir a una catedral a hacer
la hora santa la santa misa pero
obviamente las autoridades superiores no
me han dado permiso nos encontramos aquí
seis sacerdotes
seis laicos que nos tienen encerrados en
la curia episcopal
a permanecer
sin irrespetar a la policía
álvarez es abiertamente crítico del
gobierno del presidente daniel ortega la
relación entre la iglesia católica y el
gobierno de ortega ha sido muy tensa
desde que la represión de las protestas
contra ortega en 2018 se saldó con
cientos de muertos para los católicos
este último acontecimiento ha cruzado la
línea de represión
algo que están saliendo del límite con
la iglesia católica
en la iglesia
estamos en oración para que todo salga
bien para que lo liberen con lo que ha
pasado
es muy doloroso eres
ortega gobernó por primera vez en los
años 80 antes de volver en 2007 y desde
entonces ha ganado tres elecciones
sucesivas sin participación de la
oposición en las últimas celebradas en
noviembre del año pasado muchos de los
principales rivales de ortega fueron
encarcelados obligados a exiliarse con
la unión europea a nicaragua tienen más
de 180 presos políticos